the bite Administration is still saying
very little about three unidentified
objects shot down over the U.S and
Canada over the weekend and officials
say they do not know what they were or
where they came from however
investigators are learning more about
the confirmed Chinese spy balloon that
was down more than a week ago now the
event that initially set off alarm bells
and our Ed O'Keefe is following all this
for us at the White House Ed good
morning
Tony good morning to you CBS News has
learned a significant portion of that
balloon has been recovered and it's
being brought to the FBI's lab in
Quantico Virginia for further
investigation and today all senators are
privy to a classified briefing on all of
this a closed-door meeting they say it's
long overdue
what in the world
is going on lawmakers are sounding off
amid concerns about the trio of
mysterious objects shot down by U.S
fighter jets here over U.S and Canadian
airspace and who or what put them in the
sky someone's going to have to explain
to me why it is that more details have
not been made available to the public on
on things that are flying right over
their heads I don't see the
justification for that secrecy CBS News
has learned the object shot down over
Alaska Friday looked like a metallic
drum about the size of a small car the
one shot down Saturday over Canada's
Yukon Territory looked cylindrical and
was carrying a tethered payload and a
U.S official says an F-16 fired two
short-range missiles to take down the
object over Lake Huron on Sunday it was
shaped like an octagon with strings
hanging off attempts to recover all
three have been hampered by conditions
in those remote areas meantime new
images from the Navy show remnants of
the Chinese spy balloon being hauled out
of the Atlantic Ocean at the White House
so folksman John Kirby explained why
officials are so certain it was spying
it slowed down sped up maneuvered a
little bit trying to get a look at what
we believe to be sent to the military
sites
that's far different than the other
three objects picked up on Radars which
have recently adjusted to find flying
objects that may be smaller or slower
they weren't being maneuvered it was
basically they were being driven by the
wind no matter what they are U.S
officials say they know this there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns
well thank goodness for that President
Biden has ordered his National Security
adviser to pull together leaders from
the Pentagon State Department
intelligence agencies and the FAA to
start out how exactly to deal with these
unmanned objects going forward and the
U.S is strongly denying a Chinese charge
that at least 10 U.S spy balloons have
flown over that country in the past year
Tony
all right Ed we can eliminate
extraterrestrials but we don't know what
else at the moment thank you very much
to